we have to talk about this talking point
being used by some
on the right and even some on the left
about so-called
outside protesters in the civil unrest
that we're seeing across the country
right now in dozens of urban areas
so i'm going to tell you what's being
said i'm going to tell you
the truth and then i'm going to tell you
what the most important
takeaway is from all of this which is
that it doesn't actually matter if
protesters are coming
from so-called the outside so the right
regularly talks about so-called outside
protesters
because their priority is to make it
seem like there's not really a concern
in our country about police brutality
in the communities where the protests
are happening so when the right insists
the protesters are coming from outside
the city from somewhere else
they can disqualify and ignore the
activism
uh that is actually motivating
protesters and they can say you know
these are provocateurs
these are looters and writers burglars
people who are there for nefarious
reasons but most importantly what they
want to argue by saying
people are coming in from outside the
cities is they want to argue that not
that many people are actually concerned
about police brutality
which was the catalyst for these
protests you've also got a little slice
of the left
where you've seen the outside protesters
talking point used in the context of
framing outsiders as
the right wing astro turf whether it's
white nationalists pretending to be
antifa or
in order to make antifa and protesters
kind of amorphous or look bad or
whatever else you're seeing less of it
but it's still also not the best thing
because here's the truth
number one in terms of those getting
arrested the reports that we've seen
are that most of the arrests are people
who live in the cities or metro areas
where the protests are happening so in
minnesota there was a report about
20 percent of the arrests were outsiders
in detroit
similar numbers about 80 percent of the
arrests were from the detroit metro area
so first of all it is factually untrue
that a huge number at least of the
troublemakers are from outside areas
but here are the two really important
takeaways first of all
it would make sense that the
troublemakers
politics aside are from the outside
why well there's that phrase about dogs
don't
go to the bathroom where they eat or
something like that intuitively
of course people are more likely to
cause trouble
and destroy stuff where they don't live
it says nothing about
motive or justification for the protests
whatsoever
but it makes sense that you're more
likely to destroy a place
that you don't actually live in but
here's the most important takeaway
who cares if they're coming from the
outside you can still care about police
brutality
if you come into a city from somewhere
else mass rallies happen in urban
centers and population centers
protests happen where there are people
if you live in
northern rural indiana there aren't any
sizeable protests there because there's
such little population density it makes
perfect sense
that you would head into chicago for
example to be part of a larger protest
it doesn't mean you don't care about
police brutality it doesn't mean you're
there to commit a crime or to attack
people or to loot it just means
people are protesting where there are
people so i was reminded of this debate
that happened um around barack obama
this is he really a christian or is he
some kind of secret muslim
and at some point colin powell came out
and said
the question of whether he is or is not
muslim
is irrelevant muslims can still be
president it would change nothing about
his policies
if he were muslim and in the same way
here there is nothing invalid
about protesters from out of town much
of this country is very rural the
protests are limited to a few dozen
large urban areas
of course you're going to have people
from different places
in cities protesting because that's
where the protests are taking place
so we've got to take back this talking
point
we can't allow the right or the left to
miss the forest for the trees just
arguing about the protesters are from in
or out of the city the looters are from
in or out of the city
people are going to cities because
that's where the protests are happening
and there's nothing wrong with that